When I was looking at the difference
between the Communist system and the
western capitalist system,
I started to get underneath the belief
systems to find out what was there at
yoga was extremely,
how helpful and other thinkers that,
I'm sure you've heard me mentioned,
if you've listened to my lectures,
Nietzschean and Dostoevsky and social
knits and seem to be the people who had
dug deepest down into
those subterranean levels.
And what I found,
I think was that the
communist system was very,
very shallow.
It was predicated on a set of rational
assumptions that were generated by a
handful of people with no real
biological here or historical rooting.
Um,
and I think that the fact that that was
the case was part of the reason why when
those ideas unfolded in real time,
they were so murderous.
They just weren't imagine that,
you know,
Karl Marx was thinking,
well,
here's the game that we're playing in.
Here are the rules.
And so that he laid out the
rules explicitly and then
people made societies that
follow those rules and it turned out
that that game didn't work at all.
He just got it wrong.
And like seriously Ra.
Whereas in the west the
ideas emerged from a,
an unbroken historical
process that stretches back
probably to the beginning of
civilization,
say maybe,
maybe all the way back
to Africa who knows how,
how,
how ancient these ideas are.
And there's,
there's an unbroken con continuity
of ideas that emerged up and that,
and they're expressed in symbolic form
and it's on that symbolic platform which
actually matches our biology and our
behavior that are more articulated ideas
rest upon.
And so I found that extremely
useful and surprising.
I mean it wasn't what I expected.
And at the same time I was,
I was,
I had,
another problem that emerged while I
was dealing with this and one was that I
come to understand what group
identity meant to people.
Like you have to have a group identity
because you live with other people and
unless you have a shared identity,
Jonathan talked about this a bit.
Unless you have a central pole
around which you're all oriented,
it's all chaotic and confused and
you're in constant conflict and warfare.
It's like that's a bad thing you do.
You do not want that.
And you're all confused
individually and all of that.
That's a state of chaos.
It's unbearable.
But if you tighten up
the group identity too,
great a degree,
say like the Nazis tried to do,
then the probability that you'll come
to blows with other groups reaches a
almost a point of certainty.
Right?
And so it seemed to me that human beings
were damned if they did and damned if
they didn't.
On the,
on the one hand,
if you dropped your group identity,
then you fragmented and
degenerated into the chaos.
And if you gripped hard
to your group identity,
then you,
you tilted towards totalitarianism
and group conflict.
And then I thought,
well that was okay in the past to tilt
towards group conflict because you know,
when we had sticks and swords,
we,
we'd have a war in,
lots of people would get killed
and lots of people would get hurt,
but the entire planet
wouldn't burst into flames.
Right?
So you know,
this,
this inborn
dichotomy of,
of catastrophe that characterized human
existence wasn't something that could
spiral into complete destruction.
And so we could get away with it.
But now in a thermonuclear age,
it's like we can't get away with it,
but that's still what we're like.
We're still like that.
And so for months I thought,
oh my God,
I always believed that if you could
get to the bottom of a problem,
you could solve it.
Cause that that was sort of the
definition of getting to the bottom of it.
You know,
you get solution would emerge.
And when I got to the bottom of it,
as far as I could go,
I thought,
oh,
it's group identity and
like group fostered warfare
and catastrophe on the one
hand and degenerate nihilism on the other.
It's like,
well jigs up.
There's no way out of that.
And I had a prophetic dream at that point,
which,
and I won't tell you the details of that,
but it outlined a third path to me that,
that I had already picked up to some
degree from reading young and also Eric
[inaudible],
who is one of Young's great students.
And that was,
that had to do with the embodiment of the
idea of the hero and the individual as
the like the pathway of the courageous
individual as the mediating force between
the chaos of nihilism and the totalitarian
and totalitarianism of authority,
authority,
authoritarian certainty
that there was a third path.
And then I started to understand its
relationship to religious thinking,
mostly to Christianity,
but partly because that's my tradition,
you know,
in so far as I'm a western person say,
and I understood as well
that it had something to do.
And this was what it
was dramatized in the,
in the,
uh,
in the passion story in the New Testament
was that it had something to do with
taking responsibility for malevolence
because Christ is architecturally the
person who takes the
world's sins upon himself.
And what that means in some sense
is that if you read about history,
read about Nazi Germany,
you read about the Soviet Gulags,
you don't read as a observer looking
at what other people have done.
You read as the subject and
the object of the history.
You're both the person who was persecuted.
And the victimizer at the same time.
And you,
you have to see both of those inside
us actual forces in order to understand
history properly.
And of course that's a very,
very terrifying thing to do.
It's easier to take the part
of victim in some sense,
even though that's terrible,
right?
Because who wants to be the
victim of a concentration camp?
Obviously,
but maybe that's preferable
ethically to being the perpetrator.
But when you're reading about Auschwitz,
you're not reading about past history of
your reading about exactly what people
are like.
And that's a very terrifying thing.
And so one of the things you have to do
if you're going to take responsibility
for the nature of your being is
to take responsibility for the,
that's truly part of human nature.
And that's,
that's part of the encounter with the
shadow from the union perspective.
And you know,
one of Ewing's proposition was that the
human shadow reaches all the way down to
hell.
And you know,
we're used to thinking of religious
language maybe even as outdated
superstition.
But if you take that sort of statement
seriously from a psychological
perspective,
what it means in some sense is that the
malevolence that resides inside you,
at least in potential,
is of the same sort as the malevolence
that produces the worst things that human
beings have ever done.